je voulais vous parler de la situation
de la spa parce que vous nous avez
demandé d'en reparler et ça nous
concerne tous et vraiment ça nous a
énormément touchés
la situation de la spa elle est grave
puisqu'il recueille près de 45000
animaux abandonnés chaque année la sp a
lancé un cri d'alarmé sur la situation
de ces refuges
car il faut savoir que d'un côté avec le
confinement il ya plus d'adoption et de
l'autre il ya de plus en plus d'abandons
à cause du corps d'un virus qui veut
dire que les refuges se remplissent et
le risque il n'y a plus de place
c'est que des milliers d'animaux soit
utah nasier par les fourrières ce soir
on a tenu à donner la parole à jacques à
chaque charles fombonne qui est avec
nous si sophie cost pouvait dire à sochi
redevenir nous voir comme ça on le voit
un petit peu quai voilà merci c'est bon
merci au président de la spa pour faire
un point sur cette situation difficile
j'oserais dire merci à jean charles
fombonne d'être avec nous parce qu'on a
vu son tweet et on voulait absolument
essayer de l'aider comme on peut voilà
parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
catastrophe pour les animaux et cette
situation elle a alarmé tout le monde y
retourne aux téléspectateurs nous on dit
il faut faire quelque chose pour la spa
merci jean charles font bonne d'être
avec nous président de la spa merci jean
charles bonsoir
cyril alors c'est pas jojo c'est jacques
chassant maintien de la paix sociale
excusez moi oui je reviens en bresse
votre maman excusez moi parce que voilà
ça va bien je retiens ça va bien alors
j'ai pas trop m'a pas trop s'inquiéter
venir avec un homme était calé je
regrette finalement pas la voir se bat
vous auriez dû vraiment on adore les
animaux ici et jean-charles on aimerait
on a entendu votre cri vraiment et on
aimerait vous aider on aimerait que vous
parliez à nos téléspectateurs et on
aimerait savoir comment on peut vous
aider nous aussi parce que c'est vrai
qu'on peut pas laisser comme ça des
animaux abandonnés et là il ya des
situations d'urgence à la spa jacques
charles alors la situation elle est
urgente parce que en fait le le le cycle
normal de l'adoption est interrompue
c'est à dire que nous recueillons les
animaux alors sorti de fourrière lorsque
les animaux sont dix wagons voilà mon
chien lorsque les animaux sont divaguant
ils sont là voilà ils sont quatre à
karine vanasse décale blick parler
parler fort hier elle s'appelle mozza à
ce rallye sans dire attention captée
embrasser surnom nous embrasser son
cousin rella way
le temps d'identifier les propriétaires
et au bout de ses bijoux il ya deux
options ou il le donne à des
associations
si on nous comme la société protectrice
des animaux ou alors s'il n'ya plus
d'associations parce qu'il ya plus de
place ils sont obligés d euthanasie pour
le monde catastrophe prenons les animaux
fort hier parce que c'est notre rôle
nous respect à nous les reculs aurons
nous les éduquons nous les vaccinons
avant de leur trouver une famille gentil
qui va les adopter le problème c'est
comme les gens sont confinés nous
continuerons à remplir nos refuges
nous refusons d'être euthanasié aux
animaux statutairement seule interdite
on ne fait jamais ce qui veut dire qu'on
a de plus en plus d'animaux dans nos
refuges donc là où on peut nous aider là
où tous les français peuvent nous aider
c'est très simple nous demandons au
ministre de l'agriculture de nous est de
nous accorder une dérogation pour que
les gens puissent venir dans nos refuges
adopter les animaux bien sûr alors la
wallonie l'a fait les belges le fond ils
sont pas plus sains prévoyons que nous
on doit pouvoir le faire
on a pris contact une quinzaine de jours
sans vraiment avoir de succès avec le
ministère de l'agriculture
on n'est pas venu comme des amateurs on
est venu avec un projet d'adoption
pour faire simple au lieu que les gens
via une visite les refuges et
choisissent leur animal on propose un
dispositif dans lequel les gens
choisissent leur animal sur internet
vont ensuite rendez vous en rendez vous
avec une heure en scène comme ça ils
sont les seuls à porter refuge personnes
se croisent et ne rentre pas on leur
présente l'animal il envoie par internet
leur quittance d'adf leur carte
d'identité pour qu'on soit sûr que c'est
eux qui viennent on leur présente
l'animal comme on sait pas ce que c'est
une adoption responsable il faut que
toujours ne se plaisent
on sait pas le bilan du tout à l'aise et
le chien et d'une louche avec la
personne qui vient d'adopter est un feat
et puis ensuite il part avec l'animal et
on régularise rassak ou quand le
confinement sera terminé on est des gens
sérieux
on est les premiers assurent alors c'est
moi je suis général de gendarmerie je
vais pas m'amuser à me m'attend mais
bien
indélicatesse avec le règlement si les
gens du ministère de l'agriculture
veulent être présents les jours on fera
ces adoptions il ya aucun problème
on accueille on accueille tout le monde
mais oui je t'aime on accueille tout le
monde dans cette période il faut
vraiment que c'est sa lettre qu'on peut
nous apporter mais moi mais lorsque
certaines german cette dérogation
alors je voulais l'agriculture qui est
en charge de la protection animale
la deuxième fois déjà les noms qui ont
déjà été abandonnés ou est-ce protection
animale sa sincère alors je pense
jacques jacques charles je l'espère
vraiment avec mes petits moyens c'est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir je vais essayer de
contacter ceux le ministre de
l'agriculture pour lui en parler demain
dans l'émission pour lui reparler en off
et peut-être que vous vous adressiez à
lui dans l'émission je vais faire le
maximum je vous dis pas qu'il va dire
oui mais parce que je pense que là il ya
une très grosse urgence qu'il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose
ce que vous demandez franchement pour
moi je trouve pas ça fout je trouve ça
en plus la spa c'est quand même qu'elle
ait cessé voilà c'est la société
protectrice des animaux qui est
extrêmement sérieuse
on sait vous n'allez pas faire n'importe
quoi mais aujourd'hui c'est un cas
d'urgence et je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
les autorités agissent vite et jacques
charles votre je vous le dis voilà votre
cri du coeur on l'a entendu le hayer
aujourd'hui si vous dites de quoi vous
avez besoin
j'ai essayé de faire le maximum voilà
pour essayer de le joint peut être que
vous essayez de lui parler en direct
dans notre émission parce que ce que
vous dites c'est vraiment vraiment
simple et je voudrais rappeler deux
trois petites choses parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui m'écrivent aussi sur
les animaux et c'est aussi parce que on
a on n'a pas encore répondu complètement
à ces questions qui a des adoptions les
questions que vous vous posez les
animaux pose-t-il transmettre le kobe 19
c'est non je vous le dis c'est non
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
indique qu'à ce jour aucun élément ne
permet de penser que les animaux de
compagnie sont impliqués dans la
circulation du virus
voilà je vous le dis donc ça c'est non
donc déjà c'est il faut vous vous le
disiez doivent protéger mon animal oui
il s'agit spa gagne d'une préconisation
médical spécificités mais simplement de
bon sens en cette période de crise n ya
que les vétérinaires ne prennent pas en
consultation voilà
donc voilà il peine que pour les voilà
ils prennent que pour les pathologies
vital restaurant tout est forcément même
les vétérinaires sont confinés c'est ça
jacques chirac
oui absolument on avait peur il ya trois
semaines d'avoir énormément d'amour
d'eau que l'on prenne peur d'une
contagion possible
il n'y a pas de contagion l'argument au
delà des d2 des organismes mondiaux de
santé je pense que c'est la prestation
de déplacement dérogatoire on nous dit
qu'on peut sortir pour promener notre
animal je pense que s'il y avait le
moindre risque
le ministre de la santé le médecin
intérieur aux usa aurait dit vous gardez
vos animaux vous les caresser pas vous
les présentez pas aux enfants
si on nous autorise à l'essai on nous
autorise à vous promener avec dans la
rue ces cartes vraiment au charisme mais
je suis content parce que les gens ont
bien réagi et confiant on n'a pas
vraiment d'augmentation des abandons et
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
formidable
nos concitoyens ont compris que j'étais
de ceux qui osent et que c'était des
choses auxquelles il fallait pas croire
alors on rappelle que l'abandon est puni
par la loi est passible de deux ans de
prison et de 30000 euros damende la
personne qui exerce seulement un acte de
cruauté envers un animal encore aussi
jose ans de prison et 30000 euros
d'amendé
donc voilà je vous le redis parce que ça
il fallait bien le redira tout les jeux
ateliers ses toiles correctionnel c'est
une inscription au casier judiciaire
et ça c'est le jeune homme qui parle mal
à faire si jacques saint jacques charles
je vous le dis je vais faire le max je
vous promets pas ça va aboutir
mais je vais faire le maximum pour vous
dès ce soir pour complice organisé une
discussion entre vous et le ministre de
l'agriculture pour qu'on avance
là-dessus
merci beaucoup en tout cas si vous êtes
un homme qui aimait les animaux c'est
bien je fais un gros bisou à ma petite
salle à qui dois me regarde et vois là
et je vous dis jacques chien on va faire
le max et je suis sûr qu'on va réussir
j'espère que la semaine prochaine on va
faire les démarches de man j'espère
qu'elles sont prochaine on aura déjà des
bonnes nouvelles annoncées à nos
téléspectateurs
je le dis aussi merci je voudrais dire
encore bravo à la spa et tous les
membres tous les personnes qui
travaillent l'espère parce qu'ils font
un travail exceptionnel je vous le dis
voilà ils sont six ans aux manettes et
je les 690 salariés sont tous au boulot
parce qu'il refuse de s'enfermer
mais à l'intérieur il est nourri s'il
soigne les animaux ils nettoient leur
est pas si les problèmes et sachant
qu'ils peuvent ressortant ramener chez
eux un virus qu'ils auront qu'ils auront
pris au contact des filles sont obligées
de croiser même si les animaux le
transmettre j'accepte pour finir il ya
une phrase que j'adore mois qu'on m'a
dit c'est quelqu'un de l'expert qui me
l'a dit quand j'ai froid j'ai pris mon
animal quand j'ai acheté un animal et
c'est vrai que j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
de la spa qui m'a dit vraiment cyril
prend bien soin de ton animal parce que
pour ton animal toi pour ton animal
attendez je voulais refaire donc pour
ton amiral c'est toi pour tous pour toi
ton chien c'est une partie de ta vie
pour lui tu es tout cède absolument
absolument le l'animal ne comprend pas
autre chose que son maître alors il ya
deux choses on peut dire toute chose
pour le pour le confinement pour finir
sur une note optimiste parce qu'il n'y a
pas de raisons la première c'est que
pour les ennemis qui sont pas
abandonnées ça va être la meilleure
période de l'année
moi j'ai jamais autant vu mes chiens je
les ai jamais sarre ont brossé mind me
suis jamais autant amusé avec eu
l'habitude depuis spa toute la journée
le matin tôt le soir tard je les vois
jamais et puis nous avons mis en place
avant nous avons mis en place une
pétition pour nous aider à partir de ce
soir je voulais vous en laisser la
primeur
elle sera lancée ce soir il suffit de
cliquer pour dire qu'on est avec nous
pour obtenir cette dérogation comme les
belges
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que nous
avons fait le mur des compagnons
confiner le mur des v6 et vous pouvez
signer cette pétition sur tous les
réseaux sociaux et sur notre site
on va le meilleur intérêt de nos
réunions sur le site du confinement vous
vous prenez en photo avec votre animal
vous postez sur notre site
vous verrez sur en train de jouer au
scrabble avec mon père j'ai incarné et
en servir internationale parce qu'il ya
du berger suisse du berger allemand du
berger belge est sans doute quelque
chose d'autre elle joue au scrabble vous
allez voir cet intervalle et ben merci
jean charles compotes et je vous tiens
au courant dès demain de mai avancés
avec le ministre de l'agriculture merci
merci beaucoup à six il y aura été avec
nous